alors aujourd'hui ce qu'on a appris de
nouveau c'est ce que les premières
phrases de Pierre Palmade pendant
l'audition
donc on a il a il a avoué donc il est en
garde à vue depuis depuis hier 13h55 à
l'hôpital de Melun et donc les il a il a
dit aux enquêteurs que ils ne se
souvenait pas de de l'accident qu'il
avait un espèce de trou noir entre le
moment où il a fermé la porte de son
portail et l'arrivée à l'hôpital il a
reconnu avoir pris de nombreuses drogues
notamment de la cocaïne et du 3 MMC qui
est oui c'est une drogue de vous arrivez
ici eux ils arrivent ici ils sortent des
noms de drogues on dirait qu'ici on est
dans une droguerie
je sais même pas de quoi il parle parce
que
c'est vrai
JT il parle de cocaïne je suis sûr alors
je vais vous dire c'est impossible voilà
moi je touche pas du tout à ça et je
vous le dis un conseil ni touchait pas
voilà tous ceux que j'ai vu et toucher
zombie tu me connais bien
ils se sont tous foutus dans la merde je
vous le dis soyez agité de nature comme
moi envoyer ma mère
qui est hyper addictive et qui est
encore ou dont les épées
et en fait les commandes les effets sont
encore plus décuplés qu'avec de la
cocaïne et arrive plus vite donc là il a
reconnu avoir pris moins cher
puisque c'est une drogue de synthèse
donc il a il a avoué avoir pris avoir
pris donc cette cocaïne et cette cocaïne
de synthèse et aussi il a confirmé le
fait qu'il y avait deux individus dans
la voiture au moment des faits et que
c'était lui qui conduisait évidemment il
a exprimé une espèce de honte aux autres
cutter et il a dit qu'il était ravagé
par par cet accident parce qu'il avait
fait aux victimes et notamment à la
femme enceinte à l'enfant de 6 ans et au
conducteur d'accord alors
donc ce qu'on appelle un black out
est-ce que c'est possible ça Marie
Estelle Dupont
alors il existe une chose qui s'appelle
l'amnésie traumatique l'amnésie
traumatique donc c'est la perte de
mémoire partielle ou totale sur une
séquence de temps plus ou moins longue
traumatique donc en lien avec un
événement choquant par exemple je vous
donne un exemple tout à fait différent
pour comprendre un enfant qui est
victime d'abus sexuel il peut vivre en
parallèle de ce souvenir quasiment
normalement et puis un matin à 42 ans
avoir une levée d'amnésie traumatique on
ne sait pas quand ça survient on ne sait
pas si ça va survenir d'un coup ou pas
Brive ce qui a pu arriver c'est que à la
faveur de la prise de substances et
d'alcool l'état de conscience déjà
modifié de Monsieur Palmade et était
effectivement et conduit à une amnésie
traumatique maintenant ce qui peut
paraître peu probable c'est la séquence
de temps sur laquelle s'étale cette
amnésie entre mon il ferme le portail
donc et le moment il arrive à l'hôpital
donc ça évidemment moi je peux pas le
déterminer je l'ai pas vu c'est un
médecin psychiatre qui va faire un
examen approfondie clinique les
analystes psychologiques vont aussi
permettre de donner des indices pour
établir s'il s'agit d'une amnésie
traumatique s'il s'agit s'agit d'une
honte telle que il ne veut pas soigner
parce que la musique c'est une
incapacité de se souvenir ça n'est pas
un refus voilà et c'est cet examen
clinique qui va permettre d'examiner
aussi les comorbilités est-ce qu'il y
avait de la dépression etc et d'établir
s'il y avait un véritablement un black
out ou autre chose pourquoi pas un ictus
amnésique est un autre trouble
neurologique et l'incapacité à créer des
souvenirs sur une courte période de 24
heures lictus amnésique rétrograde
pendant 24 heures à peu près vous perdez
la mémoire épisodique c'est-à-dire vous
ne pouvez plus fabriquer de nouveaux
souvenirs ça semble assez peu probable
puisque ça ne dure pas 24 heures dans
son cas et qu'à partir du moment où il
est à l'hôpital il y a nouveau il se
peut revenir à un moment il peut se
rappeler où ça il s'en rappellera jamais
parce que un des éléments qui permet à
l'amnésie traumatique si c'est une
amnésie traumatique encore une fois
d'être levée c'est qu'il y ait un
contexte facilitateur un contexte
facilitateur c'est le fait qu'il y ait
des photos des gens qui lui parlent de
l'événement etc etc maintenant moi je
suis venu expliquer ce que c'est que
l'amnésie traumatique mais je voudrais
quand même avant toute chose
exprimer ma compassion profonde à cette
maman qui a perdu son bébé à cet homme
qui va peut-être finir tétraplégique à
cet enfant qui est défiguré et à ses
nombreuses victimes et si j'ai un
message à faire passer quand vous avez
un proche qui est en train de se [__]
en l'air avec de la drogue obliger le à
faire une psychothérapie parce qu'on
voit où ça peut conduire c'est vrai ça
c'est ce qu'on dit depuis plusieurs
jours agile oui alors les enquêteurs ont
trouvé Pierre Palmade assez peu
l'occasion finalement pendant les
premières 24 heures c'est pour ça que ça
a été renouvelé est-ce que vous pensez
parce que c'est la question que tout le
monde se pose que le fait de ne pas se
souvenir de bloquer au moment où il
ferme la porte de chez lui ça peut être
aussi une stratégie éventuelle de Pierre
Palmade pour
effacer tout ce qui a pu se passer dans
la voiture je ne me souviens de rien
est-ce que c'est pas peut-être un peu
pratique madame
tout est possible tout est possible moi
je suis pas enquêtrice de police et je
l'ai pas vu en examen clinique tout est
envisageable il faut mettre toutes les
hypothèses les unes à côté des autres il
y a une troisième hypothèse
intermédiaire entre la
n'hésite-traumatique et la simulation
qui est que les drogues plus l'alcool
plus le choc émotionnel plus la honte
momentanément ça fait trop pour le
cerveau il est saturé par le cortisol et
les hormones de stress là il se souvient
de rien on va le laisser dans un
contexte secure on le protège de
lui-même parce que là il est vraiment
dans un moment aigu très dangereux où il
est pas à l'abri d'un geste suicidaire
décanté et peut-être que il va récupérer
la parole et les souvenirs mais de toute
façon il est en état de choc même s'il
est coupable ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
n'est pas en état de choc c'est un peu
aussi un peu facile on a l'impression
que c'est quand même une stratégie
qu'ils ont mis en place puisque les deux
les deux fuyards eux aussi sont très peu
locataires si on a même un qui a dit que
voilà il s'était endormi et que c'était
le deuxième qu'il l'avait forcé à sortir
de la voiture et aucun des deux ne parle
vraiment de ce qui s'est passé passer
dans dans la voiture à ce moment là
Marie Estelle est-ce que est-ce que
c'est ce qu'on peut le jouer ça ou
est-ce que c'est on peut vite voir que
c'est du mytho et que en fait les mecs
jouent l'amnésie normalement l'expertise
quand elle est quand elle est très bien
menée avec des tests de personnalité
approfondie notamment permet de détecter
des incohérences de détecter des
simulations c'est ce qu'on utilise dans
les procédures judiciaires avec des
criminels etc maintenant aucune
expertise aucun expert n'est infaillible
j'ai envie de vous dire il y a des
personnes qui savent très très bien
simulées mais normalement une expertise
permet justement de distinguer les
incohérences et puis dans les pertes de
mémoire il y a vraiment des il y a des
éléments
neuropsychologiques qui permettent de
distinguer quelque chose de naturel
quelque chose de pathologique et puis
quelque chose qui est un artefact donc
on peut espérer que la lumière sera
faite sur cette histoire un artefact
est-ce que c'est soutenu dans la de
pourquoi ils ont pris la voiture ou pas
du tout il dit que c'était pour aller
faire des courses au supermarché pas
loin à 1 km au carrefour qui se trouve à
kilomètres
juste Myriam alors la garde à vue elle a
été prolongée elle a été prolongée de 24
heures donc jusqu'à demain à peu près
vers 14h il va être déféré directement
pour l'instant il y a de grandes chances
qui soient qui soit qui puisse rentrer
chez lui ou en tout cas mis dans une
dans une cellule d'ordre psychologique
je sais pas comment on dit mais non
normalement vu son état il devrait être
transféré en fait avec une injonction de
soins c'est-à-dire transférer dans un
service de psychiatrie dans une unité
fermée où il a pas de permission de
sortie parce que il est dangereux pour
lui-même là déjà dans un premier temps
il y a un risque suicidaire à ce
moment-là
bien sûr parce que on dit les personnes
qui m'ont dit il a exprimé il a exprimé
ça honte donc ça voilà apparemment il
s'est ça pourrait enlever voilà
restreindre les risques de de de suicide
il y a pas besoin d'avoir fait
psychologie pour se douter que cet homme
allait déjà très mal avant donc
il est évident que là il est dans un
moment aigu ou de toute façon pour faire
la lumière sur l'enquête et rendre
justice au victime il faut déjà qu'il
soit protégé lui-même et mis dans un
contexte c'est cure pour pouvoir
s'exprimer parce que plus il parlera
plus on sera de choses il est très
surveillé des policiers devant la porte
qui est fermée 24 heures sur 24 fenêtre
cloisonnées et effectivement à la fois
bien évidemment pour qu'il soit seul
pour que la garde à vue lorsqu'il n'y a
pas de pause se passe bien mais aussi
pour être vigilant par rapport à ce
qu'il pourrait être tenter de faire par
rapport à lui-même parce que les les
enquêteurs l'ont senti extrêmement
vulnérables il faut quand même pas
oublier qu'il y a quelques heures enfin
il y a à peine quelques jours il était
sous consommation de substances quand
même très très forte en très grande
quantité donc il est dans la descente
et la descente aggrave encore le risque
suicidaire aujourd'hui Myriam il sait
bien sûr ce qui ce qu'il a fait il en a
parlé est-ce que aujourd'hui on a eu
est-ce que la femme la femme qui était
enceinte s'est exprimée la femme qui a
perdu son bébé alors elle sait pas elle
s'est pas exprimée mais il y a des
proches à elle qui se sont exprimées qui
ont dit que notamment parlé du petit
garçon qui visiblement ne peut plus
s'alimenter ne peut plus parler
correctement comme avant il peut bouger
mais bon voilà il va pas il va pas très
bien il a il a visiblement souri quand
il a vu sa maman arrivait dans la
chambre quant au quant au père lui il
est toujours en réanimation dans un sale
état et et ça continue quand elle a
quant à la femme enceinte pour l'instant
voilà elle est elle est bien gardée au
chaud elle est très traumatisée parce
qu'il s'est passé évidemment
avant qu'on passe à Benjamin juste
est-ce qu'il y a des moyens pour essayer
de faire revenir cette mémoire pour que
il puisse se souvenir de ce qu'il a ce
qu'il a fait ou pas du tout ce qu'il y a
des petits qui peuvent essayer de dans
l'hypothèse ou c'est une amnésie
traumatique encore une fois c'était un
mois de poser le diagnostic dans
l'hypothèse où c'est une amnésie
traumatique oui le contexte de la
psychothérapie le fait de poser un
diagnostic sur les comorbidités le fait
de le faire parler le fait de lui
montrer des photos le fait de donner un
traitement médicamenteux pour calmer
l'anxiété parce qu'en fait chaque
souvenir qui remonte déclenche une crise
d'angoisse donc il peut y avoir un effet
de refoulement à nouveau oui tout ça
réunit c'est ce qu'on fait avec des
personnes qu'on est qu'on est trauma
graves quelle photo on peut lui faire
passer
pour recontexualiser parce que oui
[Musique]
c'est une fonction qui est très
contextuelle c'est à dire que vous
pouvez ne pas du tout vous souvenir de
quelque chose si je vous pose une
question hors contexte mais si je vous
remets le contexte de l'événement une
photo d'un musée qui était à côté etc le
comme le cerveau fonctionne par
association vous allez vous souvenir
donc si on est voilà il y a des il y a
des indices comme ça qui peuvent aider
en cas d'amnésie traumatique moi ce qui
me pose question dans cette histoire
c'est comment se fait-il que cet enfant
qui serait né vivant finalement dans la
loi il y a une sorte
d'ailleurs c'est la première chose
qu'elle a dit viable moi je pense à ses
parents vraiment avec elle
comme il dit comme je l'ai dit ici il y
a 2 jours pour moi il y a on pense qu'il
y a une on pense pas voilà